the community still reeling from a  deadly shooting that happened  inside a bar in the west valley happened  early sunday morning at pt's place near  decatur and charleston  police say 28 year old timothy hartley  was shot and killed  by 24 year old anthony balderas when  questioned by police officers balderas  told him he didn't remember the shooting  and he apologized for what he did those  closest to hartley describe him  as a hard-working and kind man  always funny always joking never mean to  anybody hard worker amazing worker  amazing friend even though you guys may  have not known him  he was an amazing man he didn't deserve  to go out that way  a gofundme page has been set up in  hartley's name we have a link attached  to this story up on our website